voilà mon rapport sur le miracle
soviétique
quelle réponse donner vous je n'en ai
pas les caisses du kremlin sont vides
et pourtant ils dépensent sans compter
aller au bout j'ai besoin de ton aide
pour décrocher une entrevue avec staline
gannett j'étais appelé plusieurs fois tu
vois je te parle j'ai combien comme
bonjour je peux démontrer toute leur
histoire
paul paul klee b mort tué par des
voleurs il est trop jeune que voulez
vous ce dont personne n'ose parler
j'ai vu le corps quatre balles dans le
dos et vous refusez de croire un vol sur
quoi travaille et il
écrit le trésor de staline
qu'est ce qui te pousse à faire tout ça
la quête de la vérité la tiennent la
leur ce qui se passe ici en ce moment à
transformer l'humanité
vont arrêter staline et avant qu'il soit
trop tard espérez-vous deux mois
exactement
[Musique]
l'union soviétique n'a rien à voir avec
la terre promise
[Musique]
staline n'est pas celui que vous croyez
dire qu'il n'y a aucun espoir